la fille
car il est où
laurent
[Applaudissements]
c'est déjà assez dur comme ça pour lui
j'imagine
d'abord je voudrais m'excuser parce que
je fais quelque chose de pas bien j'ai
touché à la joue une fille c'est pas
bien je le sais je l'aï expliqué à mes
enfants et je les fais quand même alors
du coup j'ai consulté et le psy m'a
conseillé ce petit bêtement mi saison
qui va m'empêcher de pas mal de
conneries
et puis
plus sérieusement je voudrais dire aussi
de trucs d'abord je veux m'excuser
auprès de nolwenn parce que la pauvre
elle est venue défendre un album
formidable on lui parle que de ça est un
peu chiant pour elle et moi qui suis
très sensible à la cause des femmes
battues je sais que la prochaine fois
que j'ai pu faire je prendre la parole
pour parler de ça on va me jeter la
séquence à la gueule donc j'aurai
beaucoup moins de crédits et je voulais
te remercier thierry pour avoir coupé il
ya un mois et demi la séquence avec
monica bellucci quand j enrage le
soutien gorge
est
obligé donc tu toi alors pourquoi
pourquoi faut pas que chez des jupes des
filles parce que ça renvoie à une image
extrêmement désagréable et je comprends
les filles qui ont été choqué par ça et
je le ferai plus ben je peux plus le
faire déjà c'est bien et c'est pas bien
voilà c'est bien tu es gars je suis ravi
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous il m'était
impossible ou